Hello!!
*clap*, *clap*, *clap*, *clap*
**CRASH**
Welcome to Hello...
...Neighbor
Let's play. I play this game before but the full game is out now and now it's divided into acts
how exciting
Here we are
Wow they changed it a lot, dude, damn!!
This feels like a whole new game!
All I remember was I was trying to infiltrate this man's house
for no reason.
AAND
F-For just for some reason he would get pissed off
What is this cut scene?
They're having coitus
Christian Channel
Hey man I get it. Sometimes you gotta lock a bish in the dungeon.
Oh my!
Oh, jeezus!
Oh!
Aw...
...hell no!
The rick and morty fans - have you kept locked in there
REEEE!
Here we are okay, so this is our house..? Yes? Nope. What a great parking you-- you got there, buddy
I love the art style; It's very 90's
HELLOOO MINNA-SAN, I'm hiding in closet
Man, they changed SO much, dude. This is crazy!
Alright, let's just go. I can't seem to open it..? There we go. Hey, how you doin'...
NO
He's throwing stuff
dededededededededededededede
Hey, what's up? Hey, what's up? Hey, what's up? Nice legs, dude; Do you work--
Oh god. Maybe I can break the window and sneak in that way
How do I grab stuff? It was 'E', wasn't it?
Here we go! Okay, you have to hold down 'E' for some reason. Alright, let's break his window. ha-kachow!
Nailed it
KACHOW
Wow, I'm such a good pitcher. listen I just want to know
who he keeps in his sex dungeon. I don't think that's...
...TOO much to ask. I can peep through the hole as well. Okay. That's cool. Oh. He's coming. He's coming. He's coming. He's coming
Hey, who jumps through their own window?!?!?! HE'S THREWING MILK!!!!!!
Take that! What is he doing in there taking a shit? How am I supposed to climb that ?
This is worse than getting over it. I'm doing it. I'm doing it. I'm doing it. Ah f-
Hey, you can't grab me from here. Ahahah...OH SHIT!
Oh shit! Oh.
You ca- You can jump wow what an incredible master of jumping. We need a box, hello Mr. Box.
You're my best friend,
Okay never mind, then jeezus. dOn'T mInD mE! DON'T MIND ME.
It's my box and I can do whatever I want with it hey hey what you goin, do huh what you gonna, do huh?
Oh shit crazy
BRAH!!!! HAHA
Works every time we're gonna jump up here, we're gonna jump up here
We're gonna jump up here and here and "heah." And then we're gonna place box
OH God damn it alright. We're fine fine. Nevermind. You know what they say: "Any man with a mustache, has a mustache."
Hey stop throwing things. I'm innocent
Did you "tomato" my face? Come on man I'm just trying to break into your house. How do I drop box? Right-click.
Ok and then pick up with 'E'. Right-Click, drop. Ok, ok. Have you ever been a box? I hear that son of a bitch
Dude, I'm just boxing it up dude. I'm just boxing it up. I'm just I'm just boxing it up
I don't understand your attitude. Hey hey hey hey hey
Hey, come get me hey hey
Come a little closer come a little closer come a little closer
what the hell , the banana peel didn't even w..
is that Milk ? , there it is
there it is box it up, buddy
There it is, look at No
You wiggle a little, and you fly off to space. Did they not have gravity in the 90's??
Thank you, finally. I get it Power Move. Oh
Spartans oh oh I need something to break his windows with right ok so far. We have nothing that you can really
Break stuff with to be honest. No bench could be useful, but I suppose not how about a book
Why don't we have a mustache thing this?
That's gotta-- That's gotta smash some stuff. All right. Can we break windows?
Yes, absolutely
You CAN break windows, ok. Oh god. I'm so-- SUMIMASEN! (Weeb for "I'm Sorry") Ey! He threw the milk! Dude,
I'm sorry about breaking your window, but it wasn't me. No of course of course if we can break the window. Yes. I'm a genius
I must be the smartest player in the whole world I bet none other thought of this before I did look at this
3 360 that a whoa high-five there that was sick man all right now. We're gonna break his fucking window
It's fine. It's fine. I got time
Or barricade
Or barricade it's barricaded its barricaded
What is happening we're barricading we're barricading
What is this
I Think I did something
What is HAP? Oh? What is that? He just saw a chair at me?
What are you doing buddy all right? Well we did that now so maybe now we can go in here
Is that a fucking bowling ball
Hey catch
He caught it. I'm so confusion. Oh, there's a flashlight we need that
This game! Oh wow the window repaired itself
Fantastic! There we go; Fixed it! What??
How did this happen? Fantastic, everybody.
Oh look at that. We did it. That does not look like a door thing. Okay? Oh, there's another key
Keys are good - PewDiePie 2017
Think I know where this goes!
Oh look, it's a magnet. Ah ah
Okay, we have the magnet. Let's not-- Oh my god. I don't understand why this guy has an i-- What his issue is.
I'm just trying to be a law-- law abi-- Oh, thank god he's sleeping, dude. Thank god, dude. Oh my god
I'm just trying to stack boxes on top of each other and I don't think that's too much to ask
I really really don't think that's too much to--
magnet time
It doesn't work oh
Okay well, that's a crowbar what about this oh?
Wow what is that lockpick and a crowbar we need to we need to get rid of something?
What should we get rid of? The car keys, we probably don't need. Okay. All right cool now can beat him to death
All right, we're sneaking
We're sneaking, I don't know what I'm doing
There we go wrenchy
wrenchy mein fragon thank you. Hey a shovel Wow I love shovels run run run run run
Yes, and now of course oh
Victoryy
Oh, what the what dude what?
What this is crazy?
Red key ,Red key ,Red key ,Red key ,Red key all right we need to drop something
How about yellow key? I don't even stupid yellow key, red key, Red key oh, yeah
Oh, I know where we are we're in the Attic dude
All right, can I just jump out the window then that works oh?
Wow what just happened so far everything has gone super smooth
I think we're gonna have to distract him properly this time because I think the red key goes to his living room
Oh Here we go here we go
Did we do it? We did it!
Das ist gut!
Das ist gut, ja? Very good!
High five dude I mean whamen whatever you are you know do your thing dude? We're in the basement. There's people here
There's bound to be people here
Hey
Who did that noise?
I Have a watering can, and I'm not afraid to use it. Okay. All right. I see what's happening here
We're gonna have to climb up we're gonna have to climb up on this one. As you do. There's something behind
Maybe we need to start the washing machine
It's a secret. It's a secret room! Oh my god. Timmy Timmy lived here look at his nipples
Timmy are you all right? Yes.
Yes, señor. Thank you for come and help me.
Señor Timmy, what is happened to yous?
I dont kno i turn into matress
No, Timmy! No!
So many secrets... Ha-cha! ...But where do the lies end? Oh my god, It's a secret [indistinguishable] room! Where's my flashlight?
I needed it now. I needed it now. What the hell? Is this "Prey"?
someone's been playing too much "Prah"
Maybe I shouldn't be playing this hahaha. I wish I had the flashlight
Spooky spooky hey, I can bring him you're comin' with me mr dummy
but I don't want to, Pewds-- Master Pew--. Shut up, buddy. You're not a judge of me. O God
omae wa
mo shinderu
run dummy oh no
Dummy you're back. I was just chilling goddamnit
Hey, it's me
So that's the exit can I go I gotta initiate the power in the beginning, okay?
Did he turn the power on oh he did so then I just have to exit now god fucking damnit. Oh?
Wait it's good. It's good. Yes. yatta  Oh no
run
Come on dummy we're gonna get away what the hell dummy you can't do it without me you have to
Goddamn, it get the what the fuck dude okay fine fine fine. You can have the dummy
WTF am I gonna throw?? What is happening
Dummy where are you? I just have the broom. I'm sorry dummy
That was sexual
Okay, so that was the end of Act one pretty pretty cool also
very glitchy a kind of a mess
But let me know if you want more leave a like as we always say on this channel and remember
Be good to each other and as always squad fam